au fil de votre carrière plus votre
carrière a décliner plus vos yeux sont
devenus petits
on a un physique comme le vôtre on ne
propose pas on impose
la première la première chose que je me
dis en voyant Mathieu il est amusant à
bouffon vous pouvez le dire comme ça si
vous voulez et Delphine Wespiser
peut-être faut pas confondre beauté car
ils sont vous êtes très belle voilà mais
vous n'êtes pas charismatique
vous avez quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
Béatrice je vous cache pas que le prénom
ça compte aussi
Géraldine
vestimentaire ça compte aussi quel âge
avez-vous monsieur 31 ans 31 ans et vous
habillez comme adolescent de 15 ans
tu vas faire quoi